[Musique]
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous pour
ce nouveau numéro de 7,8 débat
l'émission est consacrée à la
réouverture d'un foyer de réinsertion
pour jeunes à voisins le bretonneux
fermer en 2012 à la suite d'un incident
sa réouverture en octobre prochain est
un véritable problème pour certains
habitants une pétition a été faite par
des riverains et les dernières réunions
municipales ont même été très houleuse
sur ce sujet alors faut-il réouvrir le
foyer de jeunes délinquants avec nous
pour en débattre ce soir olivier afonso
vous êtes conseiller municipal
d'opposition hak lié au parti des
républicains à la mairie de
voisins-le-bretonneux et vous êtes
contre et sur ma gauche thomas quelqu'un
de gauche conseiller municipal
d'opposition ps a besoin le bretonneux
bonsoir de mons intentions alors avant
de débuter ce débat je tiens à préciser
qu on a contacté la mairie de
voisins-le-bretonneux et ils n'ont pas
ils ont décidé de ne pas participer à ce
débat alors on va débuter avec vous
monsieur alfonso pourquoi vous êtes
contre alors je voudrais commencer par
remercier monsieur quelqu'un de gauche
d'être venu sur ce plateau débattre avec
moi je regrette l'absence d'alexandre à
rosetti qui aurait pu à mon avis
apporter des éclaircissements sur ce
dossier qui ma foi manque cruellement de
de communication et de clarté et de
clarté bien évidemment
d'abord et bacton sujet est-ce que je
suis favorable ou pas à la structure
d'accueil pour jeunes en difficulté ou
globalement des jeunes délinquants en
vue de se réinsérer dans la dites
normales bien sûr que je suis favorable
à ce centre à ces centres d'accueil bien
évidemment la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est fallait-il et accepter
pour autant la réouverture de ce centre
à la grande île moi je m'y oppose alors
je suis pas tout seul effectivement vous
avez dit qu'il y avait des riverains je
mets au pouce pour une raison qui est
relativement simple le cadre de vie à la
grande île se dégrader de manière de
manière assez conséquente c'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est les riverains ceux qui
y vivent on a des commerces qui sont
fermés depuis longtemps malgré la
promesse avec sandra oh et il a adoré ou
leur ville le leader price exactement
des commerces qui se ferme en cours de
route des services à la population comme
la pmi qui ferment sur décision de la m
le maire qui est conseillère
départementale également à cela vous
rajoutez un foyer de jeunes actifs
on sait pas trop ce que ça vient faire à
la grande île on avait plutôt l'habitude
de résistance de résidence pour un
lapsus de résidences pour étudiants
c'est ce qu'on savait faire de mieux un
voisin par rapport au plateau de saclay
ça a du sens c'est logique là on va se
retrouver avec un faux agent actif plus
de 100 logements plus de 100 véhicules
qui vont donc circuler à la grande île
comme si finalement le problème de
circulation n'existait pas à la grande
île comme à voisins et à cela vous
rajoutez donc cette réouverture du
centre
excusez moi du terme mais c'est la
vérité pour jeunes délinquants qui vient
de nulle part on l'apprend par la presse
je vous assure qu'on entend qu'il eut
c'est assez surprenant voilà moi je
m'oppose pour une raison qu'il simple
cadre de vie se dégradent et il va se
dégrader encore encore plus après ces
fermetures dont vous avez parlé à soit
aussi c'est pas la mairesse qui a pris
cette décision c'est aussi le
département mais alors vous avez rendu
univers appartient au département est
allé concerne effectivement l'année vous
avez vous avez entendu ces propos vous
êtes pour
vous êtes d'accord avec ce qu'il dit
alors évidemment non autant je peux
partager un certain nombre
d'appréhensions sur l'avenir de ce
quartier le temps pour nous de ce centre
est tout à fait légitime il faut
rappeler que c'est tout à fait normal
qu'une société civilisée permettent à
des jeunes qui sont heures entre 16 et
18 ans qui ont fait des écarts qui ont
commis des écarts qui leur permettre une
deuxième chance de se réinsérer dans la
dans la vie et en même temps notre
société et nous comprenons tout à fait
certaine appréhension il ya eu des
problèmes par le passé certains
souvenirs que peuvent remonter et le
débat est tout à fait légitime et ce qui
ne l'est pas et ce qui pour nous est
très problématique c'est la polémique
qui souvent est infondée on a évoqué une
infondées il ya quand même une pétition
est signée par 1 50 super 58 riverains
et puis aussi il ya eu des incidents
parce qu'il faut savoir que c'est ce
foyer à fermer en 2012 il existait déjà
avant a servi stone et moi je comprends
tout à fait d'accord plus et poser des
questions ce que nous n'acceptons pas
c'est justement par exemple cette
pétition est plus large et plus
généralement la polémique qui a été
monté dans là dedans la pétition on
écrit noir sur blanc que ce serait des
multirécidivistes que ce serait des
criminels alors de quoi on parle on
parle de six jeunes de six personnes sur
une ville de 2000 habitants qui seront
qui sont qui ont commis des délits et
non des crimes d'après ce que la mairie
ne dit qu'ils seront encadrés 24 heures
sur 24 qui seront donc aucun moment dans
le jeu en coop c'est toi et moi je
trouve très problématique comme monsieur
l'a fait de faire un lien avec l
ensemble des deux sujets qui n'ont pas
grand chose d'avoir gagné devant leur
église et vous rebondissez je pense qui
rebondit sur vos propos qui était que en
ce moment le quartier se dégrade pour
vous cette maison il fallait la place et
où c'est à dire elle a placé à voisins
c'est un kart 7 gilles ou orlan en a
parlé de jeunes délinquants non non non
il faut il va mourir il faut éviter les
amalgames les caricatures les stades et
les stigmatisations
la pose une bonne question
quand le centre a fermé en 2012 il me
semble qu'on aurait dû faire en sorte
d'essayer de voir avec l'état pour
acheter ces lieux on a laissé simplement
la situation comme ça parce que c'est
comme d'habitude de toute façon on a
l'impression de subir les événements les
anticipent jamais dans dans cette ville
est ce qu'il y avait d'autres solutions
probablement on aurait pu envisager un
déplacement de ces jeunes
- le livre the bayou voulu qu'ils soient
dans un autre quartier de moulins le
bretonneux ceux qui prônent pour pour
ses centres et qui trouve grâce à leurs
yeux je les invite à trouver un moyen de
les amener dans leur car pardonnez moi
c'est un peu ça qui m'énerve je pense
que ça énerve énormément de riverains je
suis pas là pour représenter les
riverains qui ont été élus quand même
par il est quand même inconcevable
énervant même d'entendre certains vous
faire une leçon de morale sur des choses
qu'ils ne subissent pas qu'ils ne vivent
pas au quotidien donc c'est sûr
effectivement chacun dans notre ville
doit prendre sa part de 2 sur ce sur ce
sujet là enfin il ya un retour
d'expérience on sait comment ça s'est
passé dans le passé on avait les mêmes
garanties vous dites que vous avez des
informations de la mairie moi je leur
mets pas en tant qu il a eu les mêmes en
commission il est présent tous les deux
mois je voudrais juste réagir mais c'est
des propos qui
choquent moi je n'ai cours je les
comprends pas où vous avez commencé ce
débat votre première phrase c'était pour
dire que vous compreniez la nécessité
d'avoir ce genre de la totalité dans un
deuxième temps on est d'accord pour
défendre mais pas chez moi donc c'est la
norme chez moi même extrêmement ils sont
comme ça que j'ai dit de dire qu'il faut
que la société permettent à ces jeunes
de se réinsérer encore une fois ils
seront encadrés et il n'y a aucune
raison particulière pour que avoise ans
pas ça se passe particulièrement mal
quand ya à peu près une quinzaine 18
centres similaires en ile de france
pourquoi est-ce qu'un voisin on aurait
des soucis à chaque fois je n'ai pas
conduit par le passé ça ne veut
absolument pas dire qu'il y en aura pas
dans la suite moi ce qui me ce qui me
questionnent c'est que vous commencez
par dire que c'est soit légitime pour
ensuite me dire mais pas chez moi je
voudrais quand même dire quelque chose
les ces jeunes qui sont placés là ils
sont passés par la justice donc et un
juge qui à un moment a dit qu'il était
apte à s'engager dans un processus de
réinsertion ils seront encadrés par des
encadrants qui sont formés c'est leur
métier de faire ça c'est l'état dont
l'aller létard a comme responsabilité
c'est son rôle de permettre à ces jeunes
de se réinsérer lequel lequel de ces
personnes ne fait pas bien son travail
pour que vous puissiez nous dire que
forcément il y aura des soucis que
forcément un tel un tel dispositif
entraîne des désagréments pour les on
dit souvent que la gauchère un peu
laxiste sur ces questions de sécurité
voilà est-ce que vous avez l'impression
que la danse qui dit on retrouve
certains discours qu'on peut en vivre il
est pas laxistes je suis à côté de la
plaque pardonnez moi
non mais un moment donné c'était kembo
faut aller voir les rues vengez pas si
vous les avez vus moi je me suis
déplacée j'ai été à la grande île j'ai
même adressé un courrier aux riverains
j'ai discuté avec eux je comprends
qu'une mère de famille soit inquiète je
comprends que des grands parents qui
font vivre leurs enfants pardonnez-moi
soit 1 qu'il faut comprendre
l'inquiétude la question aujourd'hui
c'est la méthode c'est que nous avons
appris ce projet par la presse comme les
riverains je ne comprends pas d'ailleurs
que vous puissiez accepter cette manière
de faire nous avons toutes envie de vous
préciser que ce projet est sorti terre
aux loisirs au mois d'avril dernier tout
à fait et que vous avez appris ça au
mois de juillet je n'ai même plus loin
on a appris ça exactement au mois de
juin par un réseau de d'adhérents à nos
associations qui nous ont alertés
monsieur gaffe tôt qu'il représente
entre voisins ma ville et moi même nous
allons co signé un document ensemble une
lettre à l'âme le maire pour participer
à une réunion publique elle avait
organisé en catimini donc elle avait une
elle organise des concertations à la
carte elle nous a opposé une fin de
non-recevoir c'est juste inadmissible un
projet pareil demande de la
communication de la clarté du
rassemblement or aujourd'hui peut-être
que vous avez les garanties moi je n'ai
pas les garanties sur les moyens qui
sont mis en oeuvre pour assurer la
pérennité en fait des deux
métier tu n'as du quartier et pire
encore il ya un comité de suivi qui est
annoncé normal rosetti pour l'instant je
précise quand même que c'est pas vrai la
mère ait eu cette information la
mairesse on n'essaie pas elle qui est
enfin l'origine de police nationale
précise et en aval est valable pour
trois mariages et le sens où le comité
de suivi et j'insiste pour alain pour
tous les membres de l'eu de fin pour le
groupe d'opposition droite gauche droite
gauche nous devons avoir un représentant
de chaque groupe densité mythes et de
suivi or j'aimerais bien quand même le
maire s'engage à le faire alors pour
l'instant c'est silence je voudrais
alors peut-on alors être nommé mettons
nous d'accord sur quelque chose comme ça
on reviendra sur le foyer même si vous
aviez eu les informations au mois
d'avril et en plus on en a discuté
durant la préparation de ce débat est ce
que sincèrement ça vous aurait mis
d'accord parce que vous clairement vous
auriez préféré qu'il soit mis ailleurs
et pour vous c'est une chance pour eux
deux
qu'ils soient là donc est-ce que ça vous
aurez vraiment mis d'accord le vrai
problème de fond ce qui pose province
qui vous pose problème c'est que vous ne
voulez pas qu'il soit à la grande île
moi je voudrais même accentuée je pense
que on est beaucoup plus pragmatique que
ce qui nous est proposé si on veut que
cette réinsertion se passe bien il faut
absolument pas que quand les jeunes
arrivent dans la ville il arrive dans un
climat d'hostilité dans un climat de
méfiance de 20 climat de suspicion et
qu'avant même quand un de ces jeunes est
ni le premier pied dans notre ville on
est déjà des comités qu'ils soient
montés des pétitions très très exagérées
qui ce qu'ils se libèrent des fêtes qui
souhaitent écrite et effectivement il ya
un problème sur la question de la clarté
de la mairie sur ce sujet mais pas tant
sur la question de communication qui
effectivement un sujet mais surtout sur
la question la clarté de la mairie
vis-à-vis de ses positions là la
première action de que la mue que madame
la maire a eu ça a été de dire nous
aussi on regrette que l'état nous a mis
ce centre fait apprennent pas normand
niveau c'est pas une mère doit accepter
que ce centre existe depuis déjà de
nombreuses années ce n'est pas une
nouveauté que ce que ses locaux à ce qu
à présent un voisin est l'objet la
mairie aurait dû au lieu d'analyser en
creux c'est polémique en refusant de
prendre une position claire elle aurait
dû dire très clairement aux pieds nous
allons tout faire en sorte pour que ça
se passe bien nous allons évidemment
créé réputée physique c'est la moindre
des choses et je rejoins effectivement
il faudrait que le délit soit associée
mais surtout nous allons nous allons
faire en sorte que nous puissions pas se
développer ce genre de polémique et moi
je voudrais même élargir je pense que
depuis attendus nombreux mois on a je
finis juste sur de nombreux mois on a
une certaine droitisation du débat matin
que cet élément là en est un parmi
d'autres et c'est pas le seul sujet
qu'on a vu ces derniers mois et nous
nous révoltons nous regrettons beaucoup
que ce genre de polémique soit monté et
nuisent complètement à la fois à
l'efficacité de ce projet et à la teneur
des débats dans notre coeur moi j'ai aux
questions monsieur accurso et
vous allez me répondre de manière un peu
courte et concise mais vous l'avez très
bien fait si jeune on parle de six
jeunes dans ce foyer ils vont vraiment
détruire le
enfin le quartier de l'agrandir
s'enfermant moi je vais vous dire je
pense pas avoir été présent dans la
précédente expérience je ne sais pas ce
que disaient les mes contradicteurs et
ceux qui étaient en place à l'époque qui
présentait probablement ces jeunes comme
des jeunes aux crânes siffle ça a fini
par un incendie criminel
c'est ce qui a conduit la forte odeur
qui recentre d'accord donc aujourd'hui
je ne sais pas les motifs pour les pour
lequel en fait ces jeunes sont dans ce
dans ce centre moi je demande simplement
de la clarté de la transparence
si on avait été clair dès le départ sur
ce projet nous ne serions pas là enfin
entre pas forcément d'accord je voudrais
insister sur un poids et qu'on finira
suis en fait on en finira là dessus il
ya quelque chose que je trouve
profondément injuste on a eu un projet
ou plutôt le grand paris voulait nous
imposer un tracé pour le métro sous la
bretonnière sur le quartier doit y tenir
vous allez vraiment rageant et faire un
collectif s'est créé s'est battu et je
félicite pour le résultat obtenu les
élus que nous sommes nous sommes
surpassés nous avons su rassembler pour
faire en sorte d'obtenir gain de cause
alors dites-moi sur un projet comme le
grand paris c'est des millions c'est vos
impôts sélénia ce qu'on a été capable de
faire à la bretonnière on serait pas
capable de faire la grande île je
n'accepte pas cette injustice au niveau
des quartiers je comprends mais bon le
grand paris c'est pas aussi le foyer
qu'on peut faire à la gorge à landreau
mais j'ai bien compris
compris qu'on pourra pas vous mettre
d'accord sur le sujet au moins vous êtes
venu défendre vos arguments et je vous
en remercie c'est la fin de ses études
débat on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]